the jurogan experience the amount of
stock trading that's done by members of
congress the amount of [ __ ] money
that they make
when they know decisions that are going
to be signed and passed they know laws
they're going to be put into place they
know like there was one recently they
were talking about nancy pelosi and
the amount of money she invested in
tesla
right before biden signed this ev bill
electric vehicle bill it's like like 1.2
million find out if that's true
they should all have to put their money
in trusts while they're in office that
are done in
[ __ ] mutual funds index funds things
that are auto generated
buying
and not individual stocks well insider
trading is against the law yeah how is
that not insider trading right if you
know that someone's going to sign a bill
and that bill is going to be a massive
boost to the electrical vehicle industry
just as an example and you know that
bill's going to be signed so right
before that bill signed you buy a
fuckload of stock in electrical vehicles
and then the next day
or whenever it was that bill gets passed
and then that stock goes up and you make
a [ __ ] ton of money
how is that not illegal they put martha
stewart in jail for stock trading
remember that right for illegal uh
insider trading yeah how is it
what the congress does how was that
they shouldn't they should not be able
to buy and sell individual stocks
especially not [ __ ] where they have and
then keep an eye on their [ __ ]
brother-in-law too because they're
exactly making some phone calls exactly
or their husband yeah yeah well that's
the nancy pelosi thing yeah she's worth
like 200 million dollars hmm she makes a
couple hundred grand a year jesus
it's crazy
i need an inside tip man i need i got
one inside tip in my life from a friend
of mine when i he was a guy i went to
high school with and then he was on wall
street he never gave me any stock tips
and then um i had made so i got my first
development deal and he calls me up one
day and he whispers
he goes by i'm not going to say the
stock number because i don't want him to
get in trouble but he he gave me the
inside tip and i bought it at 15 and i
put a lot of money in and it went up to
20 and then it doubled and then it
doubled and then it doubled and it was
all the way up to like 350 bucks a share
and i said my strike price is 400 i'm
[ __ ] selling this at 400. i would
have made hundreds of thousands of
dollars
and uh and then it went 325.
and then it went 250
and it came all the way i sold i sold
like half of it on the way down so i
made some but it came all the way down
with it this all happened within a month
it went up oh it was a pump and dump
is that what it is yeah they do that
they trick people into buying the stock
and then a bunch of people also buy the
stock stock price goes up right and then
you sell and that was what happened with
like gmc and
hold on pelosi's husband invested in
tesla but not as viral post claims
okay so it's [ __ ] uh house speaker
nancy pelosi purchased 1.25 million
dollars in stock from the electric
vehicle company tesla a day later on
january 25th president joe biden signed
an executive order requiring all federal
federal vehicles to be
excuse me
a day later after she buys 1.25 million
dollars in stock on tesla biden signs an
executive order requiring all federal
federal why can't i say this federal
vehicles to be electric
says partly false
it's true that pelosi's husband invested
up to a million dollars in call options
for tesla stock in december according to
the financial disclosure documents
claims that the representative bought
1.25 million dollars in shares one day
before biden's executive order are
inaccurate the facts a viral meme
wrongly accusing pelosi of investing
millions in tesla the day before biden
signed an executive order on electrical
vehicles circulated widely on facebook
on monday with millions of views
more than 275 000 shares the post paired
a picture of pelosi next to a photo of
biden signing the order uh
in some versions of the post the banner
over the top of the images used sarcasm
to eloquently
to uh obliquely rather
uh suggest pelosi engaged in insider
trading reading wow what are the odds of
that talk about luck what are the odds
keep going it's true that the husband
paul pelosi made a tesla investment
recently according to the house
speaker's financial disclosure documents
per published on january 21st however
the date and the amount of the
investment don't match the claim that's
circulating wildly online according to
pelosi's latest periodic transaction
report filed with congress her husband
on december 1st invested between 500 000
dollars
and one million
and so it's only off by a little and 25
call options for the tesla stock at a
strike price of 500 in march of 2022
call options are financial contracts to
give the buyer the right to buy shares
of a stock for a certain amount the
strike price
until a set expiration date biden signed
his executive order directing federal
officials to transition federal state
local and tribal government fleets to
clean and zero emission vehicles on
january 27th more than a month after
pelosi's husband made the investment
yeah but
for sure she knew he was going to do
that
that's only a month
difference well it's not saying a day
later it's still a million dollars and
it's a month later so it's inaccurate in
a sense
but it's accurate that they
they had to have been discussing well
it's also one of the most widely traded
stocks in america true but that's a
giant decision that's made that boosts
the stock significantly and for sure she
has an insider track on it and also
how'd you get a million bucks to invest
where is that coming from well didn't
you how much is she worth 300 million or
something where'd you get that right
trading yeah it's all trading what does
her husband do is he a trader good
question i don't know
he's really good at if he's a trader you
know you can mirror uh pelosi or
anybody's trades you can track what they
hold in their portfolio can you can you
just buy what they buy you can buy
exactly what they buy
it's it's federal people do that show on
tick tock like i'm just buying what they
buy looking at yeah killing the game
yeah that's a good move just fine with
that
yep maybe she's just a genius
maybe yeah but so it seems like he
bought a million dollars worth of stock
a month before they signed that order
that seems like that should be an issue
that seems like it's controversial
no i mean there's
those kind of decisions are discussed
yeah like transitioning of the entire
fleet to electric vehicles that's not
something someone comes up with on a
whim the day before they write that down
and say it in front of the world that's
something that gets discussed yeah
i assume wouldn't you assume
uh i don't you know i don't know if
who knows i know that i was gonna buy
tesla and my my broker talked me out of
it and then it [ __ ] went crazy your
broker talked you out yeah he said that
the fundamentals were bad their supply
chain wasn't gonna be there when they
they couldn't meet the needs of all the
teslas that they were selling which was
all wrong